so let me ask you this though who's your
celebrity crush i love harry styles and
anthony joshua okay i know i know
anthony joshua is who's that guy
meghan markle's husband
big man tenure is castillo first aka the
main event aka the sniper bat shout out
to your baby now big man senior we live
in a world full of clout chasers bravo
and i'm sick of it why can't a real g
let me find some real love brad do you
think i'm a couch chaser do i look like
a child chaser
yeah how this is gonna work is i'm
actually gonna slap money in front of
these galbraith 1000 for my eternal love
and i'm gonna try and find out if the
girl them are here for the money and
clown or they're there for real love big
man thing this is cloud chasers brad
so my name is angel i do influencing
also do acting and stuff like music
videos not on the twerking side more
like you know acting and looking good
and all of that but also i'm studying as
a chef at the moment that's my main goal
so i'm here because i'm going on a date
with casilla and hopefully that goes
well
what do you do more important
love
i do not like chilling i like to work a
lot and you know i think about my future
and stuff and i want him to be the same
as me because that would help us both in
the future he needs to be tall i'm not
gonna lie
looks of course an amazing personality
and funny
yeah
not much though
would you be with a broke man i've been
with workmen yeah would you expect the
man to pay
on the first date yes
but i wouldn't mind like halfing when we
go out when we are together like in the
future but on the first day like hell
yeah i'm not paying for it
[Music]
hello
you look nice i'll give you a hug
what's your name again castillo what's
your name angel angel nice to meet you
that's the government name that's a gut
yes that's actually my government i have
nothing to do
you look nice thank you everything's
just working right now to outfit
everything is it yeah yeah the baby has
a nasty do you like my baby hairs i like
your oh thank you they're not girls
though what are they they're individual
they're like cemented in they ain't
coming out
really yeah i thought they were girls
but the glasses too thank you i
appreciate it see i made an effort done
so where you just travel from uh i
traveled from hastings actually which is
three hours away
yeah three hours away is that near
brighton
i ain't never been there in my life is
that near birmingham
but
are you being serious sounds like
they're birmingham i'm not gonna lie how
much you spend on the nails
actually it was for collaboration
pigmenting hustling people in there
yeah
so what is it that you do speaking of
work so i do influencing but i'm also
studying at the moment as a chef i like
that i like that i do music videos but i
do wear like acting
more more than anything i see that
anybody famous up in there which which
famous music video people i've worked
with um i've worked with fredo central c
and
aj tracy big mounting pressure and pain
out now on all digital platforms but we
think about their thing so you've
mentioned you dropped some nice names up
in there yeah so have you dated anybody
famous no never in life never
on the bucket list
oh no
bucket list i'm just saying jeez what do
you think of females man i'm just saying
it could be on the bucket list i've got
a bucket list you want to date someone
famous i want to date someone female
okay how about like wolf smith's wife
like what do you think no thanks no
thanks are you serious yeah brother it's
a bit mad why shout out to will smith
brother are you getting me i want to i
want to know how you like will smith but
you don't like nah bev i feel like
they're doing a madness to work why not
brother because i like will smith you
know he's a goat for doing that but also
it kind of messed up his career kind of
10 years come on 10 years well let's say
for example you was married yeah 10
years deep yeah you're getting a little
bored maybe you're feeling like the
thing's not going well and a new young
man come through he's an r b singer
and he starts putting the moves on you
making you feel special what are you
doing you're staying loyal i've been
with my man for 10 years of course i'm
gonna stay with him like just because
someone is like good looking and young
and like you know
making money in their own way rapping
artists whatever like it doesn't really
matter because like you've built this
relationship with this man that you're
with for 10 years
so you're about loyalty you're a loyal
of course it's very loyal loyal yeah
what's your name absolutely never ever
cheated on somebody never in life never
cheated
never even on a video shoot you've got a
little bit
no like big man saying why you look up
like that because it's like people
people actually think oh yeah you're
doing this with a man they didn't but
it's actually not like we're so used to
these people that we already know what
they are like and what they are you know
sometimes do you like move to us and
stuff which is like normal if you do
find someone attractive you do go for it
right
you keep it strictly business yes of
course yeah so have you ever had one of
them trying to put them in he's like yo
baby
of course so what's your response like
no i'll just be like yeah i'm not really
like interested so what's your longest
relationship three years three years
that's a long time how about yours
actually you've been asking me so many
questions i need to ask you some
questions four years four years that's
long as well i was doing mad cheating
though so technically don't count breve
i'm not gonna lie you did a lot of
cheating mad cheating that's why i'm
trying to change my ways that's why
we're hating i'm trying to find love
what made you
make this show made your own show
basically because basically my following
my profile is raising on a mating yeah
yeah so literally i've got to get my
priorities in order i'm trying to say i
got to make sure i get the right one
because there's a lot of clout chasers
up there yeah i'm gonna say so i'm
trying to weed out the mattings and get
a good one that's why i made this show
have you got a big following yes we've
got a few big mentions so how many
people was following me 51k how many men
is it and how many manners are there is
mainly man or mixture yeah well i don't
actually reply to my dm's a lot so
you're selective of who you apply to so
of course that's what you can't just
report to everyone unless you want to
like obviously appreciate what they say
to you like or they say you're beautiful
i'd reply like thank you cause someone's
like yo babies my cat died i looked at
your picture and it changed my life i
feel good now you're playing
no why not he's cat dying man you don't
want to give himself of course he's just
changed to get my attention okay so you
know when they're changing of course so
you know about you know about the boss
man's in there like morning morning
morning morning morning beautiful
so many of them and literally like it
could be like once a month or once every
day for a month or a year so you've got
men them just chatting to themselves in
there do you get a lot of those stuff
i've got a lot of dms and it's a bit mad
that's what i'm trying to weed people
yeah so i don't even i don't i don't
reply to dm's i'm not gonna lie to you
you don't no what kind of message do you
get from females somebody will just send
me a video of their name
moist
and you don't want to go there because
you don't know what kind of symptoms is
in there germain is imaging i don't know
how phil's gonna do that though i'm
telling you you don't know who's who
either you don't know is that how easy
for you to get females you just get dm's
from a guy a girl that's got like
they've sent you [ __ ] pictures and then
that's it you can go to it if you want
you see all kinds of stuff but you don't
even know what people are these days
brother you get me very inclusive
brother could be a it could be a man a
woman a mixture of both you don't know
who's sending your pictures bev
that's what i'm saying it's very it's a
dangerous word but it's very dangerous
oh my god i mean that's why you get pics
hell no i get that no no to be fair i
had a brother in there sending me videos
of him twerking it was a bit
uncomfortable i was like yeah i was like
i found i'm not the right audience for
them videos
yeah i mean but i didn't want i didn't
want to shut down his thing and be like
yo suck your mama why did you watch it
from the first place because i was like
i was thinking to myself wrong why go on
for this brother then i was like is this
brother twerking i was like what the
hell's going on
okay so he was interested where he was
doing babies no i was just thinking to
myself why is somebody sending me this i
was going to report him brethren getting
put on a register because that's not on
instagram no on a full register you know
the register i'm talking about the
several register rev
that's why i was trying to get him on
that rev
get me because i didn't consent to that
break big man team you get like man
sitting there for willian now in there
oh yeah
i get a lot of freaking pics and videos
have you ever checked somebody and said
don't do that yeah of course but like
don't don't send me that so you'll be
like yo fam i've gone on your page i see
your whole wife and kids on there bro
relax yeah actually some men have
girlfriends when like i go on their
profile and they have [ __ ]
girlfriends and they're messaging me and
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
tell me to message you have you ever
done that though no i've never done this
no no never you ever felt too i'd feel
like if i was in this situation i
wouldn't i wouldn't want my man to be
doing this so why would i let a guy do
this to her so you're like yo i am
coming to you as a woman
then one's there
no one's dangerous i'm not gonna lie
when you're looking for a guy there's
the money matter i'm not saying they
should have money when they're with me
but they should have enough money to you
know for to provide for them enough
money for you though i wouldn't just you
know start dating a guy because he's got
a lot of money he's a millionaire or
whatever thousands he's got
like it's nice to have someone that does
have money but he that's just bonus you
know speaking of which big man saying i
ain't got no peace bro shout out to the
hmrc brother ain't got nothing but
everything got nothing for you bev so
let me ask you this though who's your
celebrity crush
i love harry styles and anthony joshua
okay i know i know anthony joshua is
who's that guy he did you know how harry
styles is meghan markle's husband tink
harry styles
that's him in it the house do you know
who one direction is
no no
where's he from he's from england
or south
i don't know actually i think it's it's
near like leeds area he's done any
chains and lines in there sorry has he
done any tunes of nines do you know who
do you know are you being serious you
don't know who harry style is you said
the directions and i thought you were
talking about south do you know who sang
the what makes you beautiful
[Music]
some that's an ed sheeran tune with
oh my god i've never heard of that
brother but shout out to him bravo big
mounting hope he's watching he's his
song is i think it's number one right
now
in the world has he got a tune of nines
though if he ain't it's not it's not
really it's not really that is it
well check it out my spotify you get me
back pressure i'm paying out now and all
digital platforms get me but what i got
asked you this year so
i'm looking at you giving you a
compliment on me what's your favorite
feature on me i think your personality
that's not a feature bev i'm not feeling
that
no like i love the i can't really see
your face because of the glasses can you
take it off no
see it's not gonna lie so well how can i
say that if i can't see your whole face
because you've got the melanin rev you
know the melon in right your face shape
is good i'm talking about your nose
you know what the melanin is your color
i don't know
you got a nice nice color pigmenting
make sure you say that bread for the
people that are out there brother she's
got nice skin colors big man sing shout
out to blm bro i'm respecting that i'm
respecting that so let's say for example
you've been going after your guy for a
little while
yeah and then you basically find out
he's been chanting some next girl you're
on a party or whatever and the girl
comes up to you and she cusses you the
[ __ ] out and says why is this idiot
looking at me bob and she said she's
about to put hands on you are you
defending yourself of course how are you
going to bust her up yeah i might have i
don't know what are you going to are you
going to be if i was wearing a wig on
that day i'm going to have to take off
my wig and big man so you would mess her
up yeah of course if she's going to
cheer for that so i've
yeah exactly you can't just let someone
call them violate the thing so you bust
them up for real yeah but they gotta
act like physical first before me
because i'd look like a bad person if i
hit them first so you've got hands in
that yeah i'll just get my hands ready
whenever she hits me i'm i'm ready
respect for that i'll write them things
there that's why i gotta ask you that
i've gotta be real yeah so
this thing i'm doing like i said is love
or clout so i'm looking for the right
one yeah yeah so what are you looking
for in a man obviously loyalty
i obviously want them to support what i
do and
when you say support in what you do what
do you mean i don't know just anything
that i do in life you know like my
studies my career everything and i don't
want someone that stops me from doing
what i love doing so let's say for
example if you're a man and you're like
yo babes harry what's his name
harry styles is asking me to come on a
video shoot he's like yo babes i'm not
really feeling that you know i know
man's not really feeling you're going
there i don't want you to go down i
don't feel comfortable what are you
saying i'm actually going to his concert
next month pigmenting so it's a bit peak
in it isn't it pig harry styles but i
don't think that would ever happen
though so let me say this though you've
been with your man for a little while
you've been five years deep and you say
babes i'm going to the harry styles
concert next week yeah and you go there
you're having a good time yeah and then
he's literally then he walks past and
he's like yo what i'm going babes what
are you saying you're trying to get your
number what are you doing oh that's hard
you know why is it hard you've been on
your man for five years yeah he's my
idol like basically so if i see him i
don't have to [ __ ] him or do anything
with him too
have you ever dated yard man you dated
any yards i feel like you've dated the
odd man before i've dated someone wild
yeah that's that's not a yard man
brother you know what you're
administered no actually
what is it you know do you like movado
or vado like popcorn
yard man are you a yard man no bev but
you know who they are though don't you
no you don't know who my father is like
well how are you oh you know this megan
harry guy bro you don't know who marvado
is you don't know the golly god oh my
god
you don't know you don't know
hi
the teacher cartel where is this coming
from pigment you don't know did you make
an artist rev
the odd man
you know lindsay bashment
bachelorette yeah no i don't think that
i don't i don't know i moved to england
six years ago it's like i'm a bit like
neat everything oh i see okay it makes
sense i was trying to work out how you
don't know the gully guy no i haven't i
lived in england for six years i was
born and raised in the philippines they
know about vibes in the philippines
don't yeah of course we do we do love um
we do love um
[Music]
yeah
i swear that was like the 70s that's a
big man still like that's it
that's a bit mad still we're so it's all
good
talking about freakiness i'm a freaky
guy yeah i'm not gonna lie to you would
you say you're a freaky girl i'd say i
am what's freaky to you i don't know i
i'll ask you first what is freaky to you
freaky is like well my level of freak is
different like so
have you ever been in public before like
i've been in tinseltown toilets once
parks
i've done parks you've been in a park
before parks yeah during summer during
summer yeah with my ex yeah in the
daytime like yeah that was i was with
for like three years where was he from
like country he's jamaican so you know
yard man yeah but he's like he's very
like
is he a jafakin like would be real
jamaica no i mean like he grew up in
croydon he's mix so it's a bit like he
didn't really
have that you know what i mean like
he wasn't introduced to that uh so he
wasn't really having a curry gotten rice
he was more of like a yeah he does love
jamaican food like jack chicken because
you're making him sound like a square
brother you're making him sound like
it's a potato faces in spaghetti hoops
kind of brother i'm not gonna lie you
said the public thing you like the
public thing yeah so i gotta ask you
this don't get offended and all that
stuff you're getting up a bit or swallow
swallow
big man ting swallow cheers to that you
gotta swallow it you can't spit it out
okay i'm not chewing
for that i don't know
that's a matter isn't for you but no not
for me i
that's you know
that's the real top freaky guy levels
right there that's how i know you've got
a swallow you can't spit out big man
it's disrespectful because that's
disrespectful for them so sloppy
this is wild um yes don't know are you
saying that he's just for real no i'm
being for real but it's like it's a bit
like what's your biggest turn off for a
man what don't you like when he moans
more than me
oh for real you don't like visualism
it's an epidemic right now i mine a lot
and my man's moaning more than i am
that's a bit like whoa like
so learning about what though in bed
like when you have oh you mean monon
sexually at home
do you moan a lot you look like you do
yes
yeah let me ask you this do you like
dirty talk
yes i've done it many times on texts and
calls and i'm talking about in the
moment in the moment yeah of course
that's what you've got to do big
mentioning
the thing is that what if like
like if a girl is just laying down there
doing absolutely nothing that's a bit
boring for men you've got all both
you know i mean like sorry that's right
because some girl that is getting better
and it is dead yeah that's a bit mad
still yeah would you ever do only fans i
feel like a lot of people would play top
tier for that i'm not gonna lie let me
tell you i do have an only fans big man
team plug your teammate i do i do
yeah check my only friends what kind of
content can we see
just to make sure i don't do any naked
stuff on any fans that's just one of it
okay my name is
yeah it's like you can get 5.99
subscribers subscribers what can i get
for 5.99 probably like bikini picks i
want to do some sports like you know i
mean like gym workout videos in it and
some cooking like cooking because i love
cooking myself so i want to put some
cooking videos in it because i don't
know what it is cooking window like
you're just making a meal or you're just
making it spicy in that making a meal
like actually spicy like this one said
like you dressed nice and saying that
the momentum is watching all the men
watching you make it like a egg and
bacon sandwich type thing do you have to
look nice and make sure the food looks
nice too
have you got a lot of subscribers on
there nowadays men don't actually
subscribe
your fans if you have nothing no naked
stuff in it because like i get messages
from men saying oh why don't you have
any like naked stuff like cool
i'm like only friends actually for any
anything
a lot of females do
you can go in there and see all kinds of
things yeah they think that oh yeah
she's they need them they're thinking
they want they've got the nun bread on
there there's some titties yeah yeah
they're getting outside of fire you're
getting like
have you ever been to dubai i've never
been to dubai would you ever go
i would i mean i heard a lot of mad
stuff happens over there yeah you could
go to prison from what like smoking weed
i'm not talking about that but i'm
talking about
some toiletry issues over there
i had gala going over there
to be real toilets and that to what to
be toilets brev
what do you mean by that they're going
over there madame was just dropping
mad doo doo's breath
no life
it's a real thing
so big man senior so i've had a great
date with you so i gotta ask you this
yeah yeah how have you found the date it
was really nice you had a good time i
wish i i've asked you more questions
before you wrap up you can ask me one
more i'll give you one more question
what do you want to ask what do you
think of our date i think it's been a
great day
do you know i'm not gonna lie i thought
you was gonna be a bit still when you
walked and i was actually mad beautiful
night you're gonna be dry i'm not going
to lie if i was going to have to get the
vaseline out for you it was going to be
a bit dry bro but you you was lit yeah
i'm trying to say so i have a great i've
had a great day yeah so let's cheers to
that cheers to that
big man
thank you that was a lovely day mountain
thank you so much thank you
for that thank you
get back to
bricks then wherever we're right now
that's it that's a big mention so yo
mandem you saw when you saw that yeah
she could you see that man that's that's
top level machinery right there about
big mountain yeah so we'll see what i'm
doing next get me
cloud chasers bev
do you think i'm a couch chaser do i
look like a child club chaser
yeah so is that on your checklist like
you must eat them eat the party in that
yeah like it's a it's a criteria like
you definitely have to i look good like
i know you want me yeah i think no sorry
if we're gonna have sex and you want me
to
con it then you're gonna have to go down
there and eat it like a goosey soup like
do you know what i mean it's an exchange
do you go i mean
you